Welcome to Computer Vision.
Today were going to this might be the
last one of the lectures on just sort of
this collection of stuff, that I, maybe
not be thought of core computer vision,
but just stuff that I thought
you guys should be exposed to
one way or the other.
Also want to give a shout
out to a Kelsey Hawkins,
who helped produce some
of the material here.
So that's opposed to all the other
people that I stole things from,
since Kelsey's actually my student and
put this talk together,
I thought I would, I would do that.
But today I want to talk to you a little
about, a little bit about depth sensing.
I would say that this is tremendously
driven by the fact that there's a lot
of work recently in Computer Vision
dealing for robotics.
The re, recovery of depth previously had
been a bi, back in the 60s, 70s, and
80s, had been a big focus
in Computer Vision.
Then things sort of moved away
into more certain motion things,
labeling stuff, processing a video
to extract stuff, and, and
of course processing all
the images on the web.
But in the last decade or so, with the
growth of robotics, there's this goal to
be able to visually extract information
from the scene for a robot.
And a lot of that
information that's desired
is about the geometry
of what's out there.
Where is there stuff,
where is there not stuff?
What things are on the table?
How would I pick them up off the table?
So that sort of given a resurgence
to the interest in recovering
geometry that's out there.
And, of course, recovering geometry
is a fundamentally difficult problem
in Computer Vision.
You know, here is a picture.
You look at this, monocularly, and
you see a surface with
some geometry on there.
There's a certain ambiguity,
perhaps, as to what's in front and
what's behind, but
there's a question of,
well, how do you get a single image to,
to understand this kind of stuff?
You, of course,
have all these problems that intensity,
image intensity changes as
a function of the illumination.
But here's an image of same scene
lit from different colored light.
And, of course, it provides
a different image to be processed.
And yet, the geometry is identical.
We've talked about this before,
challenges of scale.
Here's an interesting picture.
When you look at this table,
you see a bunch of, white bowls, cups,
et cetera, whatever.
But if we actually were to sort of
take a look at just in this patch
right there, [LAUGH] clearly
there's not a whole lot of
interesting variation going on there for
image processing to handle.
And, you know, somehow it basically has
to be able to, to somehow figure out
from the basic extraction of this shape
that there's this cylinder on the table.
And that's generally a hard thing to do.
We also have trouble that,
color is not all that discriminative
sometimes, of what's there.
So there's sort of a,
a similarity between the foreground, and
the background.
What we'd really like is
we'd like some representa,
something that gave us
the shape directly.
And so, that we would see
something that looks like this.
And then it won't surprise you
that this is where we're headed.
So here is a bunch of
objects on a table.
And, you know, it'd be nice if the
system could just know that this was one
surface, and that this was another
surface, and these were the objects.
And, what we're going to do is we're
going to talk about 3D sensing.